tomorrow we're shooting a Master Chief
video we only have one day to get
together a bunch of different things
a Master Chief costume a police officer
costume halo soldier costume halo rifles
from Eva calm put together a bunch of
props and we need to come up with three
sets Nick and I are on the case or about
to get started
he doesn't want us to go in the roof but
we're gonna do it anyways who the [ __ ]
is up there I like to take highlighters
and mark with different colors what
we're gonna shoot on what day and then I
usually mark numerically in what order
we're gonna shoot it
how do we give up when we get off the
keys oh that's beauty finding an
umbrella in Southern California might be
difficult now we'll see it's you that I
open that door to because I was getting
ready to throw them off the [ __ ]
building Steve with messing people up
before how'd it work
I don't know yet I don't give a [ __ ] if
anybody's up here just clue me in and
this is my favorite [ __ ] basically a
small security camera that's just the
camera why are you doing
put this on I will okay take it up again
oh I am the camp
oh [ __ ] that feels really weird that's
insane
I I see them hey I see us we're a long
way away oh oh [ __ ]
Wow so we found an umbrella that's
perfect for the fire test because it was
already broken so we got a discount on
it and then we found a top for the halo
soldier the question becomes we're still
one umbrella down and I'm wondering if
my wife will be upset if we burn her
umbrella this thing's so wily and like
slippery and other weird terms used to
describe drones it's like when gran
turismo with all the driving aids turned
off there's no GPS so if there's wind
means it's flying to a side so to go
into if you have to set to crank it and
the thing is it's also because of the
Nerds no GPS there's no altitude
measurement or barometer so if I tilt it
forwards it starts to slip down so to
increase the throttle but I also end up
going faster patrols kind of like a
video game helicopter we did a little
googling found out these are the only
umbrellas in the whole city I don't know
what's going on around here but we're
gonna buy them
three sets we got to do covenant
fighting doctor's office and Club Lounge
oh that looks great
wow that's that's the tone shot yep
the tag
guys Minnesota going tanks
no way you got the tank to burst through
the gate and oh let's see that again